there is bachelor in paradise yay we
didn't have to wait too long it starts
on Monday and get ready because these
fine folks packed a lot of baggage get
out of my sight I think it definitely
was the most dramatic season that was
ever shot yep there are man tears an
excessive amount a beach brawl the drama
is just actually insane it's here good
old-fashioned dumpster fire more like
dumpster fires world starting with this
guy
Blake I made my bed and I'm gonna sleep
in it did you change the shape hit the
fan fave runner-up from Becca's season
of The Bachelorette has his pick of the
ladies big shocker it backfires place
out here putting a spoon and all the
parts weight was left with this he wakes
up so Kailyn is he leaving the patients
be sleeping with Hannah
Diddy I don't know how Blake thought he
was going to ride into paradise and
somehow be unscathed this is pretty
lucky
yep it is and this season we'll see a
franchise first went dummy from coolest
season falls in love with a woman I can
definitely picture being with her
how did things go for you paradise was
amazing it was so fun so emotional but
ultimately all worth it
we're also waiting to see what happens
in paradise with Bachelorette Hannah's
ex Big Mike
he's a frontrunner for the next Bachelor
but he's not totally on board I would
have to have a lot I have lots of
questions if I work on Me The Bachelor
I'll take stuff like that very serious I
don't care if I'm on TV or not
[Music]
[Music]